[Music]
okay everybody you can see I am joined
by Jake Antonio and Jordan who star in
National Treasure education at Disney
plus now how you guys doing today so
good how are you doing buddy I'm doing
pretty good so my first question is for
Jake Jake but all about this show is
Liam performing musically in the show in
different parts yeah are they are they
having you perform that live or is it
like awkward really silent miming
everything on set no and actually these
gentlemen will know from a few of the
performances we pre-record but then we
also do live versions while we're doing
it to kind of mix the audio for when we
do the final Master it has that Perfect
Blend of feeling like it was there and
also being mixed enough to from the
studio but now everything you hear was
played and sung uh yeah it was it was
such an honor to play a treasure hunting
musician uh but yeah my my second
passion is music
um you know literally working on album
for the next year so um so yeah to be
able to be able to do it was was so cool
yeah yeah no it's a nice surprise in the
show and I really enjoyed the
performances
um Antonio you have great comedic timing
in this performance what can your career
prepared you though the most for a heavy
comedic role like this
uh well thank you I appreciate that um I
would say there's there's one role in
particular when I was 14 years old I was
freshman in high school and there was
this community theater production of
Brighton Beach Memoirs I don't know if
you guys have ever heard of it it's it's
no it's it's yeah but it's it's an
incredible show and it it centers around
this like 14 year old kid who this like
from Brighton Beach New York and he's
like I swear to God like all these 370s
like narrating the show too and it's it
it definitely like made me want to get
more into the comedic comedic roles for
sure yeah that that's great I'm glad
that shows because experience definitely
shows now
also no problem Jordan your character of
Ethan he's we see in the beginning this
responsible play by the rules type are
you yourself that type in real life are
you like the complete opposite of that
uh I'm kind of the complete opposite but
you know after like
covet and sort of getting older as I go
I love routine routine I whole thing now
and uh you know but
it doesn't mean I don't play by the
rules I mean I I yeah I always throw the
rolls out when when you need to when you
need to I love that
um and you do such a great job and
putting on a guy who does play by the
rules so good job on that now uh Jake
are you prepared for the fan videos that
are gonna be made of Liam and Jess
shippers and do you ship them yourself
uh yeah yeah I think so I mean you know
you if the fans want it we're gonna give
it to the fans whatever the fans want
you know
um but it's also it's like I'm also a
huge Ethan and Jess fan you know um I
love that like that old school
friendship love
um so I'm always torn I'm always torn in
the show and uh but look I'm not gonna
fight if people ship the ship you know
what I mean oh yeah you respect the ship
yeah Antonio was this surreal for you
getting cast in a Disney project did you
grow up a Disney fan oh my gosh yeah I
grew up a major Disney fan major
National Treasure fan and uh watching it
again as an adult and seeing that it
still is just like so iconic and amazing
it's a dream come true to be a part of
it and to work with these awesome guys
over here really wonderful and we tell
you to say that they didn't pay me to
say that actually crazy it's crazy I
believe you guys so watch Jake Antonio
and Jordan crush it National Treasure
edge of History which is on Disney plus
now thank you guys so much for joining
me and we'll talk to you in the future
one day